a lot of my clients and their family
members live in a constant state of fear
30 years ago I mean there were very
little deportation cases and now that is
the bulk of cases that we take many of
the cases go through the Stewart
Detention Center
and a lot of attorneys don't take
Stewart cases
I really worry that if I were not in
some of my clients life that they would
be in a very difficult situation
I do what I do because I am an immigrant
I know how they feel I know what their
family members are going through and I
would hate for someone not to have the
proper representation because I know
that I'm really their last hope
I was born in the Dominican Republic and
that twelve years old my family and I
moved to the United States we moved to
New York and then we moved to Georgia I
went on to Georgia State University and
then I got a chance to work at an
immigration law firm as a receptionist
and it was really a blessing
because my uncle was picked up by eyes
you know we never thought that that
would be possible because we came here
with a green card
why's ice picking my uncle up why is he
at Stewart Detention Center when he's
not here illegally he was detained for
almost a year until we were finally able
to win the removal case and it was at
that moment I knew that I wanted to
become an immigration attorney so how
are you I'm scared I'm really scared I'm
not gonna lie I'm scared to be in this
place and I'm scared to to go back to my
country
Honduras is not a place where you can
leave freely you know now if you came
and I know for sure that if I appeal
again it will take longer as well you
know and it's probably gonna be another
year yeah I understand I mean this is
this is a very serious serious decision
that you have to make a horse as a
lawyer I always want to keep fighting we
never really give up but it is at the
expense of your freedom I would like to
say that I would like to fight because I
know that you have done everything is
possible and I and like I told you
before I'm so grateful to have you as my
lawyer
[Music]
we do a lot of these cases pro bono and
we have 1500 active cases
[Music]
the majority of my clients have lived
here for decades they have built a life
here they pay taxes they have children
here and they have lived crime free
lives and then they get pulled over for
traffic violations and you know that's
how they end up in ice detention
[Music]
so in order for me to visit a client at
Stewart normally I have to get up at 4
a.m.
it's far away it takes us about three
hours one way to get there and for years
Stewart had the highest deportation rate
in the country
[Music]
it's in the middle of nowhere cold and
isolated and just very difficult to get
access to it's difficult to get access
to the clients it's difficult for media
to get access it has a horrible
reputation
[Music]
I hear from my clients all the time
about the mistreatment these individuals
deserve that their cases be heard before
a judge so I have to fight for them and
I have to give them their day in court
and and they're grateful for that that's
what they want
[Music]
I've had many cases where my clients
come in and they said I've met with five
attorneys and they told me that nothing
could be done and we have been able to
win their case that's really why I do
what I do why I don't take no for an
answer if a client is willing to allow
me to fight their case I will fight the
case to the end line take intra Sally
Sally poor Katie no way nevado i por que
alguien Agoura su casa no tenemos una
boogaloo tanto el gobierno ah Julia de
algún from Ella penal a trabajado fuerte
mint a mi casa para puede sacar des
Infierno and estaba e yo al Burma yeah
mi casa perdido
nothing carrera el caso Asik in control
of Avila Penelope na dou Y gracias a a
OHS - yucky afuera coming familiar in
well I just I I really wish that the
immigration debate could be more focused
on the actual people
[Music]
I mean I represent surgeons nurses
teachers who are just here trying to
provide for a better life
[Music]
it's really a privilege and it's really
a blessing to do what I do
I get strength from the cases that we
are able to win it definitely brings
great joy to my life because I know I've
made a difference
[Music]
[Music]